This is a slice of something wonderful --
*gasp* UH - WAAHG!!
Hello, everybody, my name is Markipler.
And welcome back to three scary games.
Now, I'm not gonna do a gimmick this time around at the beginning I'm gonna get right into the game
And nothing bad is gonna happen.
*Are you sure about that?*
*Dark Ominous sound effect*
*Darkiplier is now here*
*GO AWAY DARK NOBODY LIKES YOU*
See?
Nothing ba-
*told ya*
Okay, so this first game is called "Skelety in the Park of Nightmares"
It's cute, it's adorable--
*looks like bendy and fnaf in black & white*
And it seems to have a kind of --
*what*
Bendy and the ink machine *Inky and the bend machine* Kinda thing go'n on here.
So! Were gonna fin-
MC: "Ah, ma tête ... Où suis-je?" ("Ah, my head.. Where am I?)
My dad was fish...
Hello-?
Oh...
Oh.
I don't remember walking through that.
Skelety, is that you?
Why are you on the Er- Er- Ea rth? *chuckling*
Why are on the Earth!? You taking over the Earth!? Is that what you do'n?
Oh, okay. Alright. Skelety Land.
I don't like that you have dick...
Oh no...th-that's...
That's your hip bone. Connected to the dick bone...
Why is there -- Ugh...
Oh...
g r o s s * d i c k *
Alright sure. This looks cool!
I like the style!
They misspelled park, but I think that's okay...
I won't judge them too much on that...
Hello-?
*No Ones here*
MC: "Il fait très sombre ici..."  ("It's very dark in here...")
Oh, do tell!
Oii-?
I don't know, hello...?
Can I open anything? Probably not...
*Mark reading* Your... You are...
Oh, no...
Por que...
Por que?
I don't know...maybe?
No?
Oh, okay...
* Non- Scary Jumpscare*
Oh!
*Wheeze...*
Oh, sorry I didn't know I was supposed to be
Scared by that.
It kinda caught me off guard a little bit there...
Alright, I see how this is gonna go.
I see what's happen - Oh...
Wow....
I can't look up exactly...
So I kinda just -
I gotta just keep my head down and eyes to the ground..
Pretend nothing bad's happenin'...
*Bendy Land or Bendy HELL*
Oo...kay...
*Static*
Oh!
.
..
...
I n t e r e s t i n g.
I'm okay with this...
This is good...
Let's go over to food land.
Or dessert land...*chuckles*
Oh, food land...don't look so fun.
Oh...
Woh...
Y'know, it DOES have kind of a charm to it.
It obviously doesn't have much of a polish to it -
but this game does seem to have a bit of a charm.
Is that a thing?
*intense, deep inhale*
*deep, intense bass sound*
Why the wombley??
Sure...
I love - ah - wh...gh...
Oh...kay, there we go.
I can jump, but I can't look up.
Woah -
*wind howling and machines clanking*
Hoah, what did I do?!
Wh...what did I do?
I have no idea what I just did...
It's awfully WET now!
And...loud?
It's...loudly wet...
Alright.
Just gonna pretend like - oh...weh...
Ah...
Okay...alright...
G'bye-!
I guess I'll go to dessert land!
With this rushing -
Water through my...
...Head...
The "LA Mine", huh?
Oh...no. LA MINE .
I think that's what that is...
Hello-?
Hoh, SHIT...
Oh, I can look up now! Why can I look up now?!
I couldn't look up before >:-(
HOOP!
Not gonna catch m-- *strange sound*
I'm sorry...?
I'm gonna ignore all the "DO NOT ENTER" signs -
and just barge my way in, okay?
MC: *Bon, il faut que je retrouve un levier..* ("Well, I have to find a lever.")
Oh...oh, oh!
Oh...ooooohhh....
I was too busy looking at the big ol' -
thing in the -- okay, nevermind -
Alright, I guess there's something going on here.
*spooky, yet silly music plays in the background*
I see.
Uh huh.
Do tell.
Go on -- Can I pick this up?
Nnnope!
Alright...didn't need it anyway!
That was -- *loud noise*
Why...?
I like the paintings on the walls...!
I think that might be the musical score --
I don't think anything's actually happening...
I think that's just the music playing...
So, I'm gonna go on as if -
Nothing bad is happening to me...
Nothing bad is...*yet*
Okay. Make sense? Good, great...
Oh...
No, can't break through that...
Oh!
Ooo!
*Loud crash* Ohh!
*yelling* Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! What the fuck?!
Hi! Hello! How are you?!
How we doin'?! Okay, g'bye...
*taunting* Oh...see ya...
Where'd ya go?
Oh, there you are...
Oh-ho no-o-o! *laughs nervously*
Ooooh...
*monster roars from behind and from a distance*
Alright, whatever you say.
Oh... MC: "C'était moins une..." ("That was a close one...")
Did I say something snarky in french?
Can I get someone in the comments to please translate that for me?
Thank you very much.
Translators: (no need, lol)
Alright, I guess I'll... *softly* whoa...
Alright...
Well, that's two down of whatever the hell I'm tryin' to do.
I'm still not a hundred percent clear...
...on what my objective is...
I guess I gotta go in there. Mort (death).
Is that "mort"? "Mort"?
What does that mean?" "Mort"? Death? Dead? (Yup!)
Mort...?
Mort, mort... (you're ridiculous...)
Alright...
(in a playful tone) MC: "et c'est ouvert..." ("and it's open...")
What did I just say...?
Ehhhh soo ehhhh
(attempting to speak french...face palm you are a dick)
Is that open now? Oh, It's open, okay!
Oh, and now I can look up! Oh, great!
Great, that's very confusing!
The whole "not being able to--"
Alright, whatever. I'm going into the "Mort" (death).
Ohh...
MC: "J'adorais faire cette attraction avant" ("I loved doing this attraction before")
Ahh...
MC: "Faut que j'arrête de parler tout seul" ("I have to stop talking to myself")
This is definitely...
*Mark speaking over the kid and making it difficult to translate shit...*
MC: "Allez, où sont les bureaux de ces pauvres types" ("Go, where are the offices of those poor dudes.")
This is definitely some, like, Bendy and the Ink Machine love story, right?
It's like a love lett -- oo, shit shouldn't have done that...
I can't quite jump in there...
Oh yeah, that's normal...dah, that's a slice of something normal...
Oh, boy!
Why am I running towards the giant baby head?!
Oh, hey, giant baby!
Hey!
You better not talk to me!
Okay, you better not say nothin' to me!
Where do I g -- Oh hi! He-he-he Ha-ha wer-kch-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha (ok I'm done trying to write Marks laughs. You get it. He's laughing)
*laughing still* You know I didn't expect that when I turned around...oh, okay...
*sarcastically* Oh, I love this game, I love it, it's great.
Ah, this is wonderful...
It is wonderful...
(slurring) This is a slice of something wonderful --
(jumpscare)
Ah! What the fu...hoa! Whoa!
Holy SHIT!
Oh, my god!
Oh, okay...
Oh...oh...oh...okay...
Oh...
Is it...?
Monster: *belts madly*
Wha...uh...oh...th...the light. Oh...uh...
MC:"Aidez moi s'il vous plait...Non!" ("Please help me...No!")
I died when I was eight years old.
MC:"Moi?" (''Me?")
Shit. Oh gah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-od...
N o w    l i s t e n    h e r e.
Alright. That was not bad. Not bad.
It was stylized. I like that.
It was obviously made by someone who didn't have a lot of technical skills in making games.
But the fundamentals were there.
Like the movement was janky...the environment was weirdly placed...
The pacing was off...
But...it worked and it had style. And it had a few scares that kind of made me jump!
Which is pretty good, so, I give it an A....
for effort and a B for execution! And a C for overall polish!
So...add that up and whatever the average score is, that's what that is.
That was pretty good. I hope the developer keeps going because that has... some potential!
A l r i g h t.
Okay, so, shifting gears a little bit --
This one is called "The Wind".
Apparently, this is a game based on a
short or an Indie film that's coming out or has come out.
And it is stylized in like old school DOS level graphics.
It is way, way, way old school.
*in a filtered, spoopy voice* This land.
There's something wrong with it.
Day 1.
The wind is blowing.
*normal voice returns* Oh, am I playing?
Holy shit.
Mark reading: "The laundry got blown away."
*utter confusion*
*High Voice* You wanna run that by me again??
*normal voice returns* This is like Oregon trail level stuff.
Okay, Lizzy is alive...Isaac is away...Emma is dead...
Gideon is away...
So, Lizzy is alone...? Oh...
Oh, god...
Oh.
Oh, this reminds me of, like, the FNaF mini games.
Oo, shit. Oo...kay.
Oh...
*level up sound effect plays whenever item is picked up*
Ohh, good. Yeah.
Oh!
Shit!
Uh...fuck! Uh...nuh...wolf...!
Get back to --
WAAAgH!!
HOly SHIT.
Doh-kay, get the GUN!
GeT THE GUN!
Hoah, GET THe GUN!
oh shit
uH, I'm out of bullets...
uH sHit, grAb tHe buLlEts --
Uh, I killed em...
I killed them ALL.
H-h-hoah, oh my god!
Okay!
This game's no joke!
Mark reading: Lights coming from Emma and Gideon's...
Oh...
But Emma is dead...isn't Emma dead...?
I thought Emma was dead...
Oh, no...
...oh, no...
Hoah, boy...
Okay -- oh, that's not good...
Stippy-steppy on that... *you're making me sick*
Oh, hi!
Hello.
"S" tree....
*unsettled* Okay.
Hiii....
Hellooo...?
It's weird how this is creeping me out like this...
Mark reading: "This was Emma's."
Oh, good!
Emma's demon bible...
*chuckles nervously* Great...
Okay, alright --
*Emma joins the game* *deep inhale*
Mark reading:"Where's your GUN, LIZZY?"
I DON'T KNOW, EMMA!
OH, GO! GO! JEEZ
DOH, GOD...GOAT!
*stuttering unintelligibly*
Hello? Hello?
Okay, I'm go, go --
WAH, WOAH WOAH WOAH
*panicked noises*
Hoah...kay....
*more panicked noises*
Oh shit...oh shit...oh shit, oh shit, oh shit --
Oh!
How is this game....
Creepy?!
Mark reading: "The preacher comes to visit."
Oh good!
Oh-ho great...
I don't like you!
I don't like you at all!
I don't like your grabby--uh...
Mara, Taker of Souls?!
Wha...
HEY!
Whoa-oah!
Don't take my soul!
No! No no you don't!
Boom...
Oh shit...
Oh shi-ha-ha-hit!
What do you mean Mara Taker of Souls?!
What do you mean by that?!
There's something here.
Oh go-oo-oo-oo-ood!
Oooh great!
I'm gonna take this.
Oh good...
...oh really...
...no...okay...i'll follow you...
...or maybe I won't!
Maybe that's a bad idea.
I'm gonna go over to Emma and Gideon's house
I'm gonna see what's up over there
Hellooo?!
No one?
Alright well this is a waste of time.
Okay, I'll follow you
Where'd you go?
*whispers* Where'd you go?
Ah where did you go?!
Ah! Oh! Oh god!
*you are dead not big surprise*
Why is this game scaring me?!
How is this...?!
What do you mean?!
Wait! But maybe if I had shot it...
*sobbing* Awww shit!
I don't think there was a chance. Okay.
That was...shockingly good!
I am stunned...at how good that was.
I am stunned.
That was great.
I loved that. That-That was flipping great.
I don't have anything else to say. It just goes to show...
...you don't need great graphics to make a horror experience, like...
That was creepy! That was creepy for all the right reasons!
and it had great execution, it had great style. The music was fitting to the theme.
It all worked!
like, the imagination is doing all the work. You don't need to have something amazing
...to pull off scares.
Like that's really cool.
Anyway...
What is this?
Get Stuffed *so this is Five Nights at Freddy's 1 Game Over?*
It is recommended to play with the lights off and your volume up. Okay
See...
Uh, I didn't actually read that because I was trying to listen. Oh...
...my god!
Oh...Avoid disappointment by giving up.
Oh! Good advice!
Uh-huh...
Oh this is weird mobility.
Collect mobile from security office downstairs. Okay...
Oh man...
*This is FNaF*
Yet I'm the problem? Mr Andrews left his music on again...
Ook- ohhhh
Uhhh...
Uh...
*Pepper? Where's Tony Stark? Your B O Y F R I E N D*
Uh...okay!
I'm going to security down...stairs...
Where I'm...
I'm sorry?! That's probably nothin'...
Probably a whole lot of nothin'...
Oh! That opened!
I don't know where my mobile would be or if I'm supposed to go over here in the first place...
No...
This is probably where I run away screaming like a little bitch baby
so I'm not gonna go here right away.
Oh never mind...
Never mind I guess I'm stuck...
Uh-huh...uh-huh...
Oh...oh! That's...
...much easier. Okay.
Glacial. Huh, must be another game that they made.
Oh...wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, hang on a second...
I, you know, I've had a lot of hallucinations
in my time in various games that I have played
Never have I seen a big, bulbous man
appear directly in front of me
because that's really frickin' weird!
Where's my mobile?
Can I have my mobile? There's my mobile.
I got my mobile!
Oh...hi...sir...*laughs*
Now that I got that, what do I do?
With my self and my life?
Do I do anything?
Can't leave without my stuff. Bag should be hanging by the lockers.
I know where the lockers are...from the...Staff room upstairs
Okay...sure...yeah...
Staff room...
...up stairs...
How far upstairs? All the way upstairs?
That's a weird place to have a staff room.
Makes it really inconvenient for everybody coming into this place.
Hello?
A drone...
Yeah, okay. Alright. That makes sense...
Hello?!
Why are there lockers all the way back here?!
It always seems impossible, and it is. Give up!
Oh, okay. Alright, good for me then...
alright, oh! Is that my bag? Oh, oh!
Hi...
Yeah that's normal.
Hi. How are ya doin? My names Mar--
A gun! Perfect!
I'll take that! Thank you!
Can I have that gun?!
That's...oh!
Ah! Hello!
*creepy background tone* Goodbye!
Ohh...kay...
Great...
Let me just tell you...
...I am...
...very happy...
...that I'm here.
I'm just gonna...
Just the emergency lights, no fret.
Oh, yeah.
Just the emergency lights.
And definitely nothing else!
Oh...hi!
The car keys aren't even in this *laughing* bag
forgot Andrews borrowed the car for lunch.
keys must still...
Yeah this is normal!
La di di di da di da!
*laughing* I am fine...
I am very fine! Okay oh hi...*quick inhale*
Alrighty then...
that's normal...
That's very normal!
All of this...
Oh, hi!
Oh, jeezums! Wow!
Alright, see you then! Have a good...
*metallic clanking sound*
Yeah It's fine!
Oh I'm lost.
Oh! Fucking criminy oh hi!
Hello Stacy! *It's Pepper*
Oh! Yeah...eh...uh...d'oh hi! Yeah!
Car keys? Where...
Now where did I put...
*romantic music* Now where did I put my car keys?
Car keys!
Oh...sorry about the invasive...
...search...
Straight to the car and driving the hell away from here!
You know what?
That's the wisest thing you've said thus far...
At least this guy is, like, cool in the face of danger.
Oh, I can zoommmm!
I didn't know that.
Alright, everybody...
Have a good day!
Hold my calls!
I'll, uh, I'll be back in on Monday! Late...
Whaaaa...
Late Monday! My flight comes in...
How tired am I? Oh, wow!
Alright, see ya! *laughing* See you guys around.
Oh man!
Hump day! Am I right?
Oh well am I workin' hard or hardly workin'?
*Looney Toons theme* Hardly workin!
Hey, how you doin?
Hey, how you doin? You know a way out of this hell hole?
You know a way?
Peek-a-boo!
*laughing*
For me?! Aw you shouldn't have!
Oh, ooh give me a hug!
Uh...hug...
Nice boobs!
Okay, ah! There we are!
Man, this is really running like a turd now.
The frame rate has really tanked.
But that's okay!
Hello!
Goodbye!
*low rumble*
Sorry, had beans for lunch.
Hey, how you doin? 'Scuse me, pardon me!
Uh, okay.
Cool.
This is a slice of something special.
Hi!
Let's assume I'm still asleep in my office and this is one weird nightmare.
*laughing* Yeah! Man you are too calm in the face of what's happening right now!
You are way too calm.
Alright, well I looked around there, I...*gasp*
*Looney Toons theme*
Not bad, but what a trippy adventure!
What a weird adventure!
What a strange, bizarre turn of events.
Um...yeah...not...
Not bad. Not...
...bad at all.
So, that was three scary games.
Just thank you everybody so much!
II you got other scary games you want me to play. put them down in the comments below.
And, uh, check out the other scary games that I played in the past.
Oh! And if you haven't checked out Cloak
and you want some comfy clothes for yourself
go to cloak brand dot com
Check out some cool stuff! I'll put a link in the description.
It's uh...
Clothes made for you...
Delicious...delectable
...comfy clothes...
Check 'em out! And, uh thank you so much everybody for watching!
And as always, I will see you in the next video!
Buh bye!
*AHH Ah AHH Ah AHHH Ah AAH*
*Don't forget to like,comment and Subscribe to Markimoo today*
Buh Bye!!!!!